bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
soy juice muñoz y en esta emisión nos
acompaña alejandro loaiza fotógrafo y
cineasta que acaba de ganar el
prestigioso festival de sundance con su
ópera prima utama que en quechua
significa nuestro hogar una película con
una gran tensión entre el presente y lo
ancestral con el cambio climático de
telón de fondo y sobre todo un mensaje
de amor y ternura ubicada en el
altiplano boliviano narra la historia de
una pareja de ancianos quechua que
mientras cuidan de un rebaño de llamas
se están quedando solos en el pueblo
debido a las sequías en ese contexto
aparecerá su nieto veamos un fragmento
del tráiler
[Música]
alejandro loaiza bienvenido la
entrevista de france 24 y muchas
felicidades por el premio muchas gracias
un gusto estar aquí
utama es una historia de amor entre dos
adultos mayores que hablan quechua que
están ubicados en el altiplano boliviano
se trata de una historia poco frecuente
y esto puede sorprender al espectador
porque llevaste una historia de márgenes
como esta al centro de una narrativa
como la cinematográfica
creo que lo que más me interesaba contar
era una historia de amor genuina de una
pareja que no necesite nada más que el
uno al otro y que esa necesidad y que lo
tienen que sostenerlo todo y que eso sea
amenazado la verdad es que ha sido a
veces es indescifrable y reconocible de
donde nacen las ideas pero si sientes
una enorme urgencia por contarlas y creo
que si el caso de tama
virginio es el protagonista adulto mayor
y él se resiste pese a estar enfermo
pese a que sus llamas se estén muriendo
de sed a abandonar su tierra y eso
incluso pese a que su nieto quiera
convencerle para que vaya a la ciudad a
estar mejor tratado esa defensa del
hogar como una como un espacio de
protección me resultó muy muy
interesante y es mejor para ti no sé si
es tu mensaje morir en casa que tratar
de limitarse a sobrevivir en una ciudad
si yo pienso que no debe haber nada más
difícil en esta vida que te obligan a
dejar tu casa por distintas
circunstancias y cualquier circunstancia
que esté es obligado a dejar tu hogar
debe ser algo muy difícil y en realidad
esto va a comenzar a suceder con el
cambio climático ya sucede hay
migraciones forzadas por el cambio
climático y creo que será algo de lo que
quería hablar y sobre todo también
no solamente el cambio climático
siguiente no hay un proceso general en
la humanidad por la globalización y por
por el tiempo en que vivimos que tiende
a llevarnos a las grandes ciudades y el
campo queda despoblado queda reemplazado
y esa desconexión con la tierra también
es la que nos lleva a las grandes
ciudades donde a veces ya no entendemos
como como unos compatriotas pueden estar
viviendo qué consecuencias del cambio
climático con estar sufriendo y están a
sólo kilómetros nuestros entonces
también era un poco hablar de esa
pérdida de cultura de esa de alejarse
con
tierra dejar de escuchar los mensajes y
creo que es algo que está pasando en
bolivia y que puede pasar en muchos
países sé que está parado en otros
países igual y con el tiempo va va a
pasar más si es que no tomamos acciones
y esto se puede ver en la película
también como el cóndor andino tiene un
gran peso simbólico es una especie
amenazada está la forma de vida de los
aymaras andinos de los quechua también
en peligro de extinción
si yo lo veo de alguna manera si era una
pequeña
analogía una metáfora entre el cóndor
andino porque el cóndor para la cultura
incaica y después para muchas
posteriores y quizás seguramente para
anteriores tiene una importancia en lo
simbólico es el protector de las
montañas con su vuelo tan alto puede ver
cómo están las montañas y él cuida la
vida cuida las montañas y por ende cuida
la vida porque las montañas dan agua que
dan vida y al quedar extinto el cóndor
al morirse el cóndor no haber quien
cuide esa vida no a ver quién va a
cuidar las montañas entonces de alguna
forma es una analogía entre el cóndor
las montañas y las culturas que están en
esos territorios
la película como has comentado antes
también trata muchas temáticas
medioambientales la falta de agua
también la sequía de los pozos las
llamas que se mueren de sed tú como
fotógrafo te has recorrido gran parte de
bolivia y has conocido de cerca estas
problemáticas nos vamos a tener que
acostumbrar en el futuro -alejandro a
ver cómo van a aumentar los migrantes
climáticos
y yo pienso que tristemente si van a
aumentar los migrantes climate es del
problema climático es algo que todos
sabemos está muy mal todos sabemos que
estamos yéndonos hacia el desastre pero
nadie hace nada al respecto y nadie
conoce en profundidad
los problemas de su propio país y a
veces uno lo ve como un problema tan
grande que uno no puede hacer nada y uno
se va y en realidad hay mucho por hacer
hay muchas responsabilidades por asumir
y creo que eso es lo que tenemos que
comenzar a hacer en las ciudades
obviamente eso está llevado al terreno
del cine de la ficción pero creo que a
veces el contar una historia
puede ayudarnos también a entender estos
problemas
obviamente seguramente un ambientalista
un experto ambientalista lo va a saber
explicar mucho mejor que yo
pero yo quería reflejar
en una pareja en este contexto y quería
contar una historia
este es tu debut como hemos ido
comentando ha cautivado a la crítica a
la audiencia y al jurado del festival de
sundance estadounidense pese a ser una
historia tan local como la del altiplano
boliviano que puede tener estos mensajes
universales la película que le hayan
dado este éxito
y yo creo que la esencia de las
películas es lo humano y lo humano se
puede reconocer en cualquier cultura y
en cualquier persona del mundo a veces
también nos olvidamos de eso ya veces
pensamos que los problemas del otro son
muy lejanos a los nuestros
y a veces somos egoístas también en eso
entonces pienso que la universidad de
las historias está justamente en eso que
la esencia es humana y es igual no somos
iguales somos lo mismo todos en el mundo
y creo que ese es también el poder que
tiene el cine por eso es que es tan
poderoso por es que puede viajar tanto y
cine y las historias no porque uno se
puede ver reflejado en una historia
contada en uzbekistán o en uganda o en
parís o en bolivia porque lo que nos une
es lo mismo es nuestra esencia humana
nuestra condición humana y los
sentimientos humanos
esto también puede significar que el
cine pueda ser una especie de ministerio
de exteriores para los países en este
caso de bolivia
sí sin duda creo que el cine y las
historias son en la forma en que uno
cuenta sus historias cuenta al país y
cuenta la identidad del país entonces no
contar tus propias historias también te
condena a casi como digamos
simbólicamente no existir como país por
eso también la importancia para las
autoridades bolivianas de entender el
valor del cine y de la cultura porque
sirven como tú dices de embajadores que
están mostrando
están mostrando al mundo cómo es tu país
y están también haciendo una memoria y
creo que uno cuando puede cuando ve una
película no importa del año si es del
año 57 uno entiende el pensamiento de
esa época entiende la problemática de
esa época y creo que ese es el valor uno
de los valores enormes de del cine
la película deja un regusto amargo con
el futuro medioambiental que tiene el
planeta por delante pero también la
película para mí termina siendo un canto
de amor a la vida pero también a las
relaciones
crees alejandro que solo el ser humano
puede salvar al ser humano
es una pregunta bastante difícil yo creo
que
yo creo que la naturaleza puede salvar
al ser humano y el ser humano tiene que
entender a la naturaleza para salvarse a
sí mismo
creo que esa desconexión que que tenemos
con la naturaleza nos está llevando a lo
que nos está llevando y
simplemente volver a entender eso tal
vez nos puede salvar
de nuestro catastrófico fin que se
proyecta pienso igual que la película
tiene yo quería que quede un mensaje de
esperanza igual porque está justamente
en nuestras manos y creo que también la
película es un canto al amor y es una
un homenaje al
amor a un amor y a las personas
alejandro una última pregunta para mí la
película tiene un mensaje político muy
potente cualquiera que la vea en mi caso
quieren salvar de ese éxodo a virginio y
asisa de tener que irse del territorio a
la ciudad sin embargo es algo recurrente
en américa latina porque las políticas
estatales no llegan a este tipo de
personas ya estos territorios
la verdad es que eso resulta muy triste
porque hay éxodos por distintos motivos
dentro de américa latina y el olvido al
que está condenada la gente que no forma
parte de la estructura de poder o
económica es muy triste y realmente uno
va viendo eso en bolivia que si no eres
funcional si no sirves para algún
propósito económico
no hay no importa y la tierra importa
igual siempre y cuando puedas tener un
rédito económico y a veces yo lo
entiendo siendo países pobres también
necesitamos generar como país pero pero
creo que también eso es algo que tenemos
que comenzar a comprender como humanidad
y la pandemia nos lo ha demostrado que
los problemas son hoy globales no son
locales y si se espera que américa
américa latina no deforeste tantos
bosques o no sé creo que tiene que haber
también un apoyo mundial es una política
mundial con protección a eso pero que
también tengo un beneficio para los
países se nos acaba el tiempo alejandro
muchísimas gracias y sobre todo
felicidades por ese premio sundance
muchísimas gracias esta actitud un
placer haber estado aquí y muchas
gracias también a nuestra audiencia
pueden seguir más contenidos como éste
en france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]
bien